usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticada con cáncer de
ovario
este vídeo le ayudará a entender las
opciones de tratamiento disponibles
el cáncer de ovario comienza en los
ovarios que son la parte del sistema
reproductivo que produce almacena los
óvulos
el cáncer ocurre cuando hay células
anormales que crecen sin control
las células cancerosas continúan
dividiéndose y pueden expandirse su
tratamiento se basa en el tipo y etapa
del cáncer y en otros factores
importantes
los principales tratamientos para el
cáncer de ovario son la cirugía y la
quimioterapia su plan de tratamiento
puede incluir ambas opciones
también puedes recibir uno o más de los
siguientes tratamientos terapia dirigida
inmunoterapia
radioterapia o terapia hormonal
y la cirugía para extirpar el tumor es a
menudo el primer paso en su plan de
tratamiento el objetivo de la cirugía es
tratar el cáncer mediante la extirpación
de la mayor cantidad del tumor que sea
posible si usted tiene cáncer de ovario
epitelial el objetivo es también
determinar la etapa del cáncer
la cirugía incluye la extirpación de uno
o ambos ovarios
y las trompas de falopio afectadas
también pueden ser extirpadas
si se extirpa el útero la cirugía puede
incluir la extirpación del cuello
uterino
para eliminar la mayor cantidad posible
de cáncer el cirujano puede necesitar
tomar tejidos de órganos que no están en
el sistema reproductivo pueden tomarse
ganglios linfáticos o el aumento que es
el delantal de tejido que cubre el
estómago y el intestino
y la cirugía también puede implicar
tomar tejidos de órganos cercanos como
la vejiga
el estómago
o el colon
y la quimioterapia utiliza medicamentos
para combatir el cáncer los medicamentos
entran en el torrente sanguíneo y viajan
por todo el cuerpo
y la quimioterapia funciona destruyendo
las células cancerosas o impidiendo su
multiplicación las células sanas del
cuerpo también pueden verse afectadas lo
que puede producir efectos secundarios
la terapia dirigida es un tratamiento
para el cáncer epitelial de ovario
avanzado
se dirige a la parte de las células
cancerosas que las hace diferentes de
las células normales estos medicamentos
cambian la forma en que las células
cancerosas se dividen crecen y se
reparan como resultado el tumor puede
dejar de crecer o incluso reducir el
tamaño las células cercanas y sanas del
cuerpo también pueden verse afectadas lo
que lleva a los efectos secundarios
la inmuno oncología también conocida
como inmunoterapia ayuda a su sistema
inmunitario a combatir el cáncer estos
tratamientos fortalecen su sistema
inmunitario para que pueda detectar y
atacar las células cancerosas o evitar
que crezcan
y otros tratamientos para el cáncer de
ovario son la radioterapia y terapia
hormonal estos se utilizan con menos
frecuencia su médico puede recetar una
combinación de estos tratamientos
y discuta con su médico cualquier
pregunta que tenga sobre su plan de
tratamiento o efectos secundarios
asegúrese de tomar sus medicamentos
según las indicaciones de su médico